i'm curious for you guys i like throwing
a curveball at the beginning if someone
has never seen
anything that you guys have ever done
what's the first thing that you want
them to watch and why
first thing that honestly popped into my
head was vanya on 42nd street
um
i'm not in that
and as far as i could
never will is not in that either but
it's just great
the first thing
i'd like them to see
oh i don't know if i can tell the story
but i had a very short-lived cameo
on a cbs show um
what was the name of the show
dang it
my few dads no
b.j and the bear no
i'm thinking those are both great
evergreen shows sorry yeah
anyway that's where it's as far as i i
can't tell i'm sorry i had a really good
reference but i can't think of the show
it's totally cool
i'm set up as a
what looks like going to be like a a
recurring lead
and i'm uh
i'm murdered at the end of the episode
really yes
okay
i'm gonna look this
i'm going to be looking this up after
the interview um i want to jumping into
why i get to talk to you guys today i
want to start with congratulations i've
seen the first four episodes and you
guys are both fantastic in it um the
thing that really struck me was when i
heard you guys were making this i'm like
this can't be true i'm never gonna
believe a psychologist could do this to
this person but as i watch the series
i'm like oh i totally buy into this it's
these little micro moments
that you know and can you sort of talk
about that aspect of their relationship
well i think they're you know they are
it's a close relationship they i think
they care about each other um i mean it
is a a patient and therapist
relationship that certainly
crosses boundaries and
um
and over the
course of 30 years or so
i think what starts out as a pretty
solid good relationship just
takes a bit of a left turn
um
it's hard to i guess talk about without
giving
too much away um but
but it was it was this it was
the kind of the relationship between the
two men and what
makes them both kind of human that we
were interested in exploring and not so
much just this
vicious story that was true yeah you i
mean you touched on the micro moments i
mean it's it's analogous to
you know
marty's
first introduction to ike and their
first therapy sessions
are
constructive and loving and soothing
much the same way when you put a frog
into a pot of
warm comfortable water and the heat
slowly gets turned up to where
it's too late before marty realizes he's
he's been boiled
that's a very good analogy um you guys
are obviously both offered a lot of
scripts and a lot of projects what was
it for each of you that says that said i
have to do this or i want to do this
well i think a big part of it was
getting to work with each other again uh
in this way uh something that wasn't
kind of
you know super arch
you know in your face
comedy is it the challenge of of playing
real people in a uh in such a unique
story like this um
to get to work with uh michael showalter
uh georgia pritchard um
uh it just was it was very enticing and
i
i had
for me personally i hadn't
ever really done uh a limited series
before so it was a
it was a new
new experience for me
yeah when i heard the podcast which you
know right when it came out michael
showalter had called me and said have
you heard this listen to this there's
something to this what do you think
will had heard it around the same time
we both heard that each other was
interested in it and then okay we all do
it together i think it just really
stemmed from a fascinating story
really interesting characters set in a
really unique and interesting place uh
and
it was riveting it was riveting to
listen to and and we both kind of
thought these would be really
um in addition to the fact that it
wasn't a broad comedy but a complex and
nuanced uh dark comedy or with really
dramatic elements it was just
really interesting character study so
and and riveting because
you know as
as you kind of said
you think well this is so absurd how
could anyone
allow themselves
to be put in this position
uh
and and then as you go along you see
that oh it's
we've we've all felt vulnerable at times
we've all felt like we needed someone to
talk to and once that person gains your
trust it's easy to be manipulated
i gotta stop there i'm just gonna say
you guys were both fantastic in this
can't wait to finish it good luck with
the rest of your interviews thank you
thanks steve
you